so you've heard me say it this is not a
rehearsal
this is this is the emergency the postal
service says
tens of millions of ballots mail-in
ballots absentee ballots are
at risk of not being counted the united
states postal service is warning
that 46 states and washington d.c
in july they warned tens of millions of
voters
might not have their votes counted
because of the slow
mail processing of absentee ballot
applications and eventual ballots
that in april washington post has the
story
that was the earliest sign from the post
office
that if they do kneecap them in terms of
funding which the trump administration
is trying to do
it could affect ballot delivery now i
really need people to understand this
because
donald trump and trump is saying
something very different
the problem here is not the volume of
ballots okay
please look at the numbers every um
holiday season you know november
december into new year
the post office regularly handles about
1.3
billion greeting cards around the
country okay
even if every voter voted by mail
we're looking at somewhere between 120
and 130 million people voting
that's only 10 of the normal volume of
greeting cards okay
if if we just let the post office do its
thing it would have no problem handling
mail-in ballots
even if every ballot was
by mail instead of in person but that's
not going to be the case only
some people are planning to vote
absentee or vote by mail
the problem is if you cut hours
if you limit overtime if you close down
post offices
if you shut down mailboxes if you quote
reorganize
the post office the way louis de joy
wants to do
you will then cause a problem for the
post office being able to deliver
and do everything that they have to do
the warning
from the post office applies to 186
million potential voters now
not all of those voters are expected to
vote by mail so that's why in practice
it will probably affect
tens of millions rather than you know
186 million
which is the number of people that could
vote in some of these states
it's in blue states it's in red states
it's in battleground states like
pennsylvania wisconsin michigan
so there's a few suggestions here that
are just common sense
i'm going to have a story tomorrow by
the way my
ma this is i don't should i even well
i'll mention it
this is crazy my absentee ballot
application
um took 14 days to go three miles
okay i'm going to talk about that
tomorrow but as far as suggestions
request your ballots as early as you can
return your ballot as early as you can
it likely will be too late for some
people
in some states like it seems that we've
reached a post office
kneecapping escape velocity for lack of
a better term
we are unfortunately looking at a
situation where if you want
higher confidence that your vote will be
counted you might have to vote in person
now i want to be careful here i'm not
suggesting anybody do anything unsafe
but i'm talking about
wearing a mask and all of that stuff
what i am
saying is we're hearing from the post
office itself
that they are being sabotaged or
sabotaged
as as william shatner says and this
administration is trying to find a way
for your vote not to count now there is
some intermediate good news and this
made some
some uh waves over the weekend and i do
want to amplify it
in a lot of places if you get your
ballot in the mail
you don't have to send it in through the
mail you can drop it off and
different municipalities have different
places uh town hall city hall different
municipal offices figure out the
specifics in your community
in other places if it's 10 days before
the election and you don't have your
ballot for example
you might have to vote in person to make
sure your vote is going to be counted
and that's horrifying i i don't want to
pretend that that's not a possibility
but because it is
trump is against funding the post office
his postmaster general has reassigned
23 postal executives and is sort of
circling the wagons and consolidating
power
they are talking about the post office
like it's a business when really it's a
public service
you don't say we can't do it you say
okay what do we have to do to make sure
that they can
do it that's what a normal president
would do this president says let's make
sure that they can't do it
so really keep in mind that this local
drop-off might be a good idea i checked
in boston how does it work in boston in
boston
the election website says if you want to
return your ballot in person you can do
that
anytime city hall is open but you've got
to go to city hall
now doesn't seem ideal that anybody all
of boston needs to go to city hall to
return their ballots
in in person but it is something in new
york city i found that quote all borough
offices are equipped with ballot marking
devices
available for voters up until election
day
look it up in your community remember
they
want to take everything away from
government so making the post office
fail
at something as natural as just
delivering ballots
is part of them building up the case
that we should be replacing the post
office with private industry anyway
and they have the added benefit this
time around
that they might be able to win an
election if they're able to do it
very scary i i want to say this is being
taken as seriously as it should
i don't know if it is oh i'm doing
everything i can to sound the alarm
know the options understand the
timelines figure out where you can drop
off your absentee ballot in person
if you're able if you have
transportation and you're able to do it
very very important stuff because this
could get really ugly really quickly